Europe like much of the US is grappling
with extreme weather caused by unusually
hot temperatures the fires are raging
and raging his word look at these
pictures in several countries including
Portugal and France and many areas are
seeing their worst drought on record
Ramey inocencio has more on wildfires
that have forced thousands to evacuate
and one of France's most famous wine
regions
this Great Wall of fire in France a
burning reminder that one of Europe's
hottest driest summers in decades is not
over
in the southwest the famous Bordeaux
wine region again the country's
infamously scorched Hot Spot more
Village Homes charred thousands more
people forced to flee this battle of man
against nature raging day and night is a
second time in two months after
far-reaching fires from July reignited
while in France's Central burgundy
region River levels are falling further
with fish baking to a crisp in the
Summer sun
in Spain wisps of smoke seen while
flying over parched hillsides turn into
soaring plumes over firefighters in a
David and Goliath Challenge and
overnight in Portugal more than 1500
firefighters are now nearly a week into
wrestling this blaze in a national park
dumping Water by plane and by helicopter
in England a country not used to
wildfires bales of hay have caught fire
like Matchstick heads across Fields
Farmers dipping into winter feed for
their livestock this August because the
grass is just too dry to eat I've lived
here all my life I'm 24 and I've never
seen it so dry and it makes me worry
that if I'm still here in 20 30 40 years
time what the Farm's going to look like
then
here in London this park is three times
the size of New York Central Park and
just look at it it is parched and
temperatures are expected to hit nearly
100 degrees all this week and in just
the past few minutes the government
announced an official drought for
several regions across the UK Nate
thank you